so apparently this report from Daily
Mail Bahamas government ordered Fallen
crypto CEO Sam bankman free to hack FTX
systems and transfer assets to the
island nation after he filed bankruptcy
wow well then but what are we doing
about this what is the FTC doing about
this they just find Kim Kardashian a
million dollars for not putting like
hashtag ad on her Instagram post or not
just closing how much she made on an
Instagram post they're going to
investigate Twitter you know because
Elon Musk is bringing in ligma Johnson
you know we can't have that yeah that's
a big problem that guy is going to
change the world
he
bought his immunity and so the the Press
is he's getting scrutiny because of
Twitter he's getting screwed because of
Reddit he's he's not having these these
hardcore journalistic exposes coming out
in fact I think uh I think if we have
this tweet here we go look at this Jake
Shields tweeting looks like this event
uh look this looks like an event not to
miss zelenski bankman freed Larry Fink
and many more including Janet Yellen the
New York Times event November 30th 8 A.M
to 6 p.m only 2 400 to attend yeah if
you look at the partners of he who he
was working with he was working with the
Ukrainian Bank he was working with the
world economic Forum he was working with
Tony Blair he was working with Bill
Clinton he's he's working with known
people who are uh war criminals and uh
child diddlers let's be honest here he
was working with the worst of the worst
when it comes to the most powerful the
most evilest people on the face of this
Earth so I think it's fair to conclude
especially with how fast the company was
was was made so popular especially with
everyone on the corporate media Shilling
for him calling him the next JP Morgan
and Chase that there's something up here
that's a lot more than nefarious than we
actually know about I think right now we
only know very little about what
actually happened here I think a lot of
this was maybe a money laundering front
I think there was a lot of secret
shadowy money moving around coming from
one place going to another place I think
what what is what could be potentially
uncovered here is some deep down
intelligence agency connected psyops and
extortion rackets that that could
probably blow people's minds away but
again that's just speculation but at the
end of the day right now what else are
we left to think here did you guys see
that uh I think it was a lensky who said
it was a Russian missile and NATO's
wrong yep
World War III yeah he's like I imagine
that you know he does these videos where
he's like we must protect freedom and
Russia as a terrorist State then as soon
as the camera it turns off he just goes
because this dude's out of his mind no I
feel like he just ordered some of the
same hookers as Hunter has a good time
he closes the laptop and then Hunter
walks out and then he's like smoking
crackpipe but he's like good job let's
do this yeah they're on the same yacht
yeah it's not illegal because we're on
the water he acts like a movie star he
acts like a movie he is one of my
favorite Babylon B headlines that we did
after what was it hurricane Ian um that
awful it said uh president zielinski is
on a wrap asking hurricaneian victims
for money for Ukraine
well they know they need their money I
guess yeah
I feel like is this just something that
they're doing because there's no actual
real money so now they're just creating
money to kind of get more legitimate
money back into the
more real money does that make sense
There's real money well no there's not
real money but there's money that we
think is more real than others it's War
it's War that's war war what is it good
for increasing domestic Manufacturing in
March of 2020 we got off the fractional
Reserve uh system and switched to the
infinite Reserve System meaning Banks
could create Money On Demand with with
no restriction at all and print money
and instead of the IRS it takes your
fake money yeah well so the point of the
IRS is to limit Financial expansion and
inflation yes not to actually fund the
government right because modern monetary
Theory so what happens is
when a bank when you take your credit
card and swipe that money is created
yeah and that you know when a bank gives
out a loan the money is created they're
not giving you money they have and since
March of 2020 they've had no
restrictions it used to be it was like a
90 restriction so if they had 100 Grand
they could create 90 more and then what
people are complaining about is that you
create that money and put in another
bank that bank then loans at another 90
which then puts into another bank and
then they keep doing that and eventually
they were like this is dumb let's just
tell the banks they can make money
endlessly and now the money supply is
through the roof people are just
printing making it I kind of feel like
in 2008 they knew the system was
collapsing so they started preparing to
jump ship and they were like let's print
as much money as possible for ourselves
to absorb as much natural resources that
we can and enrich ourselves that when
the system collapses will be the Lords
of our little fiefdoms oh I knew in 2008
it was going to end when the dumbest
cokeheads I knew were driving sixty
thousand dollar cars and selling three
million dollar houses seriously good for
them huh yeah well I mean not really I
think they spent it all pretty quick
yeah
and here we are but it was yeah it all
worked out though I guess my advice is
uh get a nice little plot of land and
get some chickens some goats or Forest
I'm not gonna get about this
yeah we could pull this we could pull
this off we can all be in this I mean I
can I can name the forest on free
Namaste and the ligma Johnson Forest
right now
it's like 30 Acres of forested area we
have to make this a public place though
that people could come into and enjoy
ligma Johnson to the fullest extreme the
family yo exactly hold on there's like
200 acres of forested land for like a
million bucks
so all we need is a hundred thousand
people to donate ten dollars and then we
will have a public
land was it they got 20 on it right now
make it 15 and we can put bathrooms and
then you know ligma Johnson we could
adopt a highway too
it's just gonna be a town at this point
I don't know do you think that we like I
so I know where there's a big plot of
land like 200 acres for like a million
bucks and it's forested all forested
there's a road going through it and it's
it's weirdly shaped but uh
you know if we if we got
if we got uh 50 000 people to give 20
bucks
you know can we make Dave mayor of ligma
Johnson please
yes thank you we'll build a statue
because you'll be the Lord
no no no no it's you you will build a
statue of you right when you come in
it'll be like welcome to ligma Johnson
you know amen but the two pranksters the
two ogs need to be recognized so it'll
be it'll be a statue of Dave as like a
jolly old man with his arm around the
ligma Johnson guys yeah cigar in his
mouth they'll be right in there but the
like what Johnson guys have to be huge
like yeah I could be power I could be in
the middle of them but smaller I'm fine
with that I know where I stand
and then the woman who was on there
reporting the story she's just in a
glass box crying the whole time yes the
real woman we'll we'll put a statue of
her and we'll do like they do these
things out here because it's all Civil
War territory yes where they have these
like placards that are covered and you
can read about the history we'll do that
as you walk the trail the ligma Johnson
Forest explaining like it won't just
talk about ligma Johnson it will talk
about the history of the corrupt media
yes this would actually be really cool
but you'd need an extra like 10 grand
for something like that for installation
and stuff but it would be really cool if
you like walked the path and they were
like little things being like you know
in this year this you know media
organization lied about this and stuff
like that right you followed the years
back to the origin of fake news and it's
you know talking about like fake reports
like when uh who was it who was it who
reported that Napoleon had won and the
stocks crashed oh the Rothschilds is
that that the Rothschild did that they
had they had someone claim that the
Napoleon won the Napoleonic Wars and
then also the stocks were collapsing
started buying them all by crazy and
then the real world came real word came
in that he actually lost and then all of
a sudden everything that was worth way
more yeah you know so there you go like
go back to the origins of the fake news
narrative manipulation stuff all the way
to like Marilyn Monroe who's just not
oding it's just two CIA agents
MK Ultra yeah that'd be super cool you
know we do let's we buy the land and
then we let the public put up whatever
placard they want because like just shut
up and do it whatever it's public land
have fun I mean and like there'll be one
big sign at the entrance being Like You
by entering this property you can't sue
us and then at the end it says Biden
fetterman 2021 it's a no-brainer damn
right we all win we got to take back the
comments I I kind of think this is
possible this would be like a huge thing
if we were able to do it start a crowd
fund you need to raise a little bit more
for closing costs and stuff like that
find the plot of land announce that we
want to buy it and then see if people
are willing to pitch in 10 bucks to buy
the land and we'll put it into a trust
or something or like maybe we make it
available to the general public and we
make it a big Park she make it a
scholarship for journalists the ligma
Johnson Scholars yeah but I want to give
those people money you know what I mean
like I don't want to put people in
Germany yeah you don't want to you don't
want them go to they could be
actionation camps big theme park
so that would be a lot harder but you
want to be open to you know it's like 50
years later we're all old and that's
like the happiest place on Earth Park
ligma Johnson with the user coasters and
it's like Disney but you're Dave's there
and he's very old and they're like tell
us the story again Dave about how this
was around well kids it was 50 years I
couldn't stop talking about it yes the
pacifiers I just bring it back and the
condoms what if what if like
what if we like pitch this to Elon and
ask him to contribute because look the
real goal is no one's going to own this
it's going to be like a privately owned
public space in a trust so the value is
retained with the property but you
create a public park and you call it
ligma Johnson and it would just uh you
know maybe I'm pretty sure we could find
some rich people who get down on that
for sure right all right let's let's do
it I have some people who didn't lose
they got to be out there that's right
let me let me write down ligma Johnson
I'm writing it down no he's serious I'm
serious yeah he's real serious
um and uh does anybody have elon's phone
number I do you do yeah well I call
Twitter
we'll call Twitter after the show and
then um
here's an idea
we could uh somehow use the property as
a way to uh help support Twitter and
then everyone when they log in they just
see the fundraiser on the top of their
feeds powered by ligma Johnson that's
right that's right what if he what if
what if Elon changes the verification
badge to the ligma Johnson badge oh what
does our badge look like though just
balls
and just a nice set well like here's
what I'm thinking
to what degree could Elon screw with
Twitter and we'd all just go along with
it you know like already we have doubles
I would write it he could burn it down
that'd be great I know I'm I'm sitting
here it would be like 2015 Twitter all
over again fire everybody and just hire
people over the age of 45.
yeah I mean why doesn't he just strip
everything out of it and turn it into a
decentralized text feed and just be like
we got no staff protocol nobody's in
charge of it yep just protocol yeah
there you go it'll look just forever
people will use it and nobody makes
money on it yep he lose 44 billion
dollars I guess and his investors would
be really really angry he's got to pay
that debt back so I don't know yeah he
but he wants to make it WeChat he wants
to make it that we have to do almost
everything on there so I don't think
that's the vision right he uh sees with
Twitter I gotta be honest if it were me
like I would roll out a ligma Johnson
button yeah on on the left just because
because you need to you know yeah well
it's like a like button but better yeah
and every you know you could link mother
post yeah what does a ligma mean what
does the ligma mean is it good is that
like a lion look alike well yeah you
click it it's it's it well it's you know
the like implies you like it or you're
favoriting it right now the just means
you're ligament it that's it yeah I
don't know what it means it's whatever
it means to you yeah exactly
just think about
the ability to do funny stuff like that
you know what I mean like I yeah I don't
know that as well you you think you
think you you think I'm not being
serious let me no I think you're being
serious nothing's funny anymore because
everything's so crazy well everything
you say is just under a microscope and
being attacked I'm telling you right now
if you go to timcast.com and you go to
the join us page you can see uh you want
to pull that up you can see we've got
our rooster Roberto Jr and our cat bocus
in our talent tree and of course Jamie
kilstein Jamie you're still there
despite the fact that Jamie was
Consulting and now he's not here right
now but uh I put my rooster Roberto Jr
up in our really good headshots your
rooster and your cat it is very good
bocus how does the star of the show how
did you get them is it a male rooster is
that your male rooster is there a female
rooster Luke is there is there is there
such thing as a female it's it's 20 22
too
Chicken on there that is my male chicken
I like it I also put a 96 foot tall
billboard of him in Times Square
oh did you really oh yeah you did I saw
that that's a 96 foot tall picture of my
[ __ ] was up in Times Square family
friendly show here yeah yeah
what do you think we're talking about
come on come on you know that's my point
I'm just like I don't know I don't know
exactly what it did but it was something
you know I'm just waiting for Elon to
throw pie I guess he kind of is though
the lick my Johnson stuff I'm I'm I'm
I'm all for it someone's got to do
something it's getting boring yeah
that's the positive thing about Trump
you know that's why people love Trump
people were so bored and tired and they
wanted someone to you know yep
and that's what we enjoyed seeing he
still is he very clearly still is that's
why everyone's so upset about uh him
running again yes
and the meltdowns are pretty fun yeah
just to watch people lose their minds
it's fun to see the Republicans melting
down over him again yeah that was fun
I'm like yes it's 2015 all over again
I'm like he's the same people I love
DeSantis but the DeSantis Bros are
coming out in full force right now and
they're so annoying they're so cringe I
think a lot of people take themselves
too seriously yeah I think that's the
main issue a lot of people are like
Angry how dare you trigger or get angry
at Trump and I'm like well just just
stop it stop with the nonsense same with
the DeSantis does Santa says it even
announce he's not even running and you
got these guys like saying no it's going
to be DeSantis the guy's not even
running right now no his exact yeah his
exact words where I just won this
election could you calm down and let me
do my job you know so you know we could
try to do and I mean it we could we
could set up a fundraiser uh a a crowd
fund none of the money we would set up a
bank account with like a trust or
something
um we got to figure out the proper legal
way to do it maybe we actually have all
the money go specifically to like a
lawyer or something so that no one no
individual benefits from it and the
lawyer is only signed like ability is to
transfer the money for the property or
something
and then uh I I bet if we got a bunch of
other prominent personalities
um commentators on board with it we
could easily raise money to buy a large
plot I bet you could make it a 501c3 too
very difficult to do take two years two
years later we'll be having a committee
meeting to determine how we move forward
so you know a lot of people ask like
what we're doing with our fact checking
organization yeah we've been in filing
for a year and a half so uh maybe uh
after 27 months when all of that gets
confirmed we'll actually be able to do
something but that's how it goes there
there are things you can do but but you
know maybe a trust for it or something
like that maybe there's like a public
trust thing you can do I don't know
maybe you can make it so that after a
hundred years the the property reverts
to the local jurisdiction you know but
it can't ever have its name change
something like that but I I we don't
even got to do a million dollar property
we could probably find 50 acres
and get something for just a forested 50
acres find something in eastern West
Virginia I bet you could find 50 acres
for like 100 or 200 Grand they like give
away land in Kansas though you could
probably get cheaper there's parts
that's true right you can just have
like a dollar
we should do that yeah buy a whole
neighborhood I feel like it would be
even better if it's in Detroit what if
what if we went into an area where there
was at least 100 people
and then bought up enough property to
Lobby those people to create a new city
a Township inside of it well because uh
I think you need like a hundred people
to incorporate a town or something I'm
in the city of ligma Johnson
time before it already I already know
some properties but you know you know
the thing about buying forested areas
that you really can make it just like a
park and like people can come hang out
well in Detroit though you have pit
bulls and gangs of them roving around so
really yeah of course wow yeah it's been
that way forever are you allowed to have
guns yeah oh okay I don't think I mean
if you're allowed to or not you can buy
one out of a paper bag
but they are around
oh man what a sad story Detroit yeah it
was once called the Paris of the Midwest
really yeah yeah yeah they called it
that yeah now it looks like someone
dropped the nuke on it well yes well
that happened in the late 60s and it's
just sort of stayed the same the
downtown's looking nice that's what
everyone yes it is it's improving yeah
it's great yeah it's nice down there
well I wouldn't say it's improving it's
a City built for seven million people
with 700 000 living in it so right lots
of property we could buy for a town
infrastructure is really expensive
though because of that it's like 10
times the cost for water and stuff yeah
the taxes are very pricey yeah yeah but
that's why I'm saying West Virginia
baseballs we're out here yeah and I've
already seen property maybe like an hour
west of where we're at where it's like
there's a river that's nice and and some
of them even have like power conduit
like power conduits or whatever so you
call the electric company and then
they'll just put a meter and a plug the
power on but I think they're actually in
a frozen homeless guy in An Elevator
Shaft that's been abandoned for years
and we can have that you're saying again
well now I'm sold I'm just trying the
ligma Johnson Elevator Shaft and then
what we'll do is we'll immortalize the
Frozen homeless man with the statue at
the bottom of the chef and maybe he'll
come to life like Encino Man okay except
it'll just be not fun to hang out with
them we can have a shaft cam I'm
watching all that stuff you know what's
funny
what if we do this what if we crowdfund
what if we crowdfund a city
okay I'm for it we we buy the property
and then basically open it up to whoever
wants to build on it to build on it like
there would have to be an approval
process obviously yes because we're
going to allocate land but someone could
be like I want to have my own store and
it's been like the land is yours like we
lease the land on on the property to
your store so long as you maintain it
we'll do rules like if at any point you
give up the store for longer than a year
then the property opens up and we can
lease it out to somebody else but the
goal is not for people to own ligma
Johnson it's to create a crowd-funded
city I feel like a crowd-sourced city
yeah so they can just come they don't
have to pay and they can let's think
about Johnson they're the ideas yes my
idea is this if we get the property and
you come to me and say I want to open a
gun store we'll say where right there
how much space do you need I need one
acre signed one acre for this amount of
time if you abandon the shop then you
give us the right to lease the property
to somebody else so we can keep it going
but you're not we're not taking money
for it we're just basically like okay
first come first serve we're gonna
crowdsource that's what they did in L.A
let's get wrong oh first come the first
sir yeah but
with it being in the middle of nowhere
you're not going to get derelict
individuals because there's no easy
there's no stuff they're not going to
walk though no one's going to walk like
it's here in the middle of the woods no
what you're going to find is like a dude
who's got time and some spare materials
who's like I could put together a little
shop that'll be cool and then when
people come here they can buy Gatorade
from me like I'm down like and we're not
going to take any money for it it's like
you do your thing like if you're like I
want to set up a turquoise jewelry shop
we'll just kill you
we'll let them set up their turquoise
jewelry and then we'll burn its own no
no see this lady is like crying she'll
look like hey I'm the mayor I'd be like
yeah lady who looks like the the old guy
in thinner
I think uh I think trying to crowdsource
a village would be fun I would do it
doctor shows up and he's like I'll put
up a little like first aid medical thing
it's like have fun all you really all
you really need is someone to try and
organize to make sure people aren't
overlapping with each other and you know
stepping each other's toes yeah we can't
have the gun shop in the same well yeah
we could well I don't know this is a
liquor store yeah you want to do Anarchy
Style just let people build whatever
they want where they want yeah I mean
there's an amazing campsite
um that pork fest usually happens every
year uh at the campground that's for
sale so we could buy the campgrounds and
call it the ligma Johnson uh campgrounds
Johnson campgrounds yeah and pork fest
once a year yeah what podcast once a
year with the Free State why one way
yeah if we didn't if you meet this
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time